llega un momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está como siempre
en el estudio daniela blandón lista para
sacar cuentas echar números danny y por
cierto iniciamos con unas cifras poco
alentadoras sobre el mercado laboral
laboral en américa latina' una noticia
mala con la que empezamos a raúl
infortunadamente pues el banco mundial y
naciones unidas presentaron un estudio
en el que dicen que la informalidad en
américa latina está lastrando esa
recuperación económica no es que haya
que hacer un estudio para darse cuenta
si tienen unas cifras bastante
interesantes el informe se basó en
encuestas realizadas a 800 personas en
24 países y mostró un retroceso general
en formalidad inclusión e igualdad
durante la pandemia con relación a la
tasa de desempleo dice que 1 de cada 4
ciudadanos no lo ha recuperado sobre
todo las mujeres también se ha perdido
calidad el empleo formal ha bajado en
cinco puntos porcentuales pues hay más
trabajando por cuenta propia y la
economía se está moviendo hacia las
microempresas y si hablamos de ingresos
la mitad de los hogares todavía no ha
recobrado los niveles que tenían antes
de la crisis por el 19 como vemos en el
gráfico así es mira ni en ecuador
entrará en vigor una polémica reforma
tributaria que quiere hacer el gobierno
ecuatoriano entonces bueno pues es
polémica porque fue presentada por el
gobierno de manera urgente así que el
legislativo tenía 30 días para aprobarla
y el legislativo lo que hizo fue que no
dijo ni sí ni lo y por por eso el
presidente guillermo lasso la sancionó
para que entre en vigencia por la vía
express a partir del primero de enero
entre otras cosas la ley incluye una
modificación de los rangos de impuesto
sobre la renta y baja el monto de
deducciones de gastos también aumentará
las contribuciones fiscales de las
empresas más grandes algunos de los
tributos comenzarán a cobrarse desde
esta reforma fiscal raúl es una de las
exigencias que ha hecho el fondo
monetario internacional para seguir
desembolsando recursos al país y en 2019
recordemos que fue el detonante de las
protestas masivas cuando incluyó la
eliminación progresiva de los subsidios
a los combustibles
solo como el gobierno que hará el
próximo desembolso sería de 700 millones
de dólares en diciembre y el fundador de
twitter ya dejará de ser su presidente
porque pues raúl mire
jack dorsey es un excéntrico personaje
que en 2006 fundó la compañía y desde
entonces la dirigió ahora anuncia su
dimisión a partir del próximo año sin
ofrecer razones específicas y lo hizo
por supuesto pues como más iba a hacer a
través del siguiente tuit
se habla mucho sobre la importancia de
que la empresa sea dirigida por sus
fundadores en última instancia creo que
eso es una limitación severa y un simple
punto de falla y trabajado duro para
asegurarme de que esa empresa pueda
separarse de sus fundadores y se estarán
preguntando quién es el reemplazo pues
es el ex director de tecnología de
twitter que se llama para agrawal quien
tendrá que dejar de lidiar con asuntos
técnicos para dedicarse a los delicados
conflictos políticos y sociales de la
plataforma que tienen casi 400 millones
de usuarios en el mundo y le pregunto
qué es lo que más se recuerda entonces
de actores y al frente de twitter bueno
hay varios hitos pero que yo más
recuerde fue uno de ellos cuando cerró
la cuenta de twitter del ex presidente
de eeuu donald trump después del ataque
al congreso y también que es un férreo
defensor de las cripto monedas
recientemente vendió el primer tweet de
la historia en una subasta digital por
2.9 millones de dólares y lo hizo
mediante el sistema ntf que son toques
no fungibles o criptográficos que
también usan el blog change que es el
mismo adn de las cripto divisas y que
necesitaríamos de un programa completo
para explicar así es daniela y
seguramente en una oportunidad lo
dedicaremos a eso porque para allá vamos
ahora le pregunto por los indicadores
bueno las acciones asiáticas cerraron
mixtas los inversionistas siguen
sopesando con cautela cuánto puede dañar
la economía esta nueva variante del
coronavirus omicron en europa hay más
pesimismo que ayer el principal índice
de la bolsa de londres por ejemplo se
prepara para su peor caída mensual en un
año a medida que omicron pues golpea a
sectores como los bancos y las materias
primas para finalizar este primer bloque
económico que nos trae como cifra el día
bueno compruebes hay ver mandayona no
iba a comprar pero al final como 15
otras cosas y me descuidé yo tampoco
nivel black friday porque yo confío más
en los descuentos de enero ay si es eso
si la cifra tiene que ver con el sar ben
silverman day que arrojó una cifra
preliminar de siete mil millones de
dólares en compras esto según lado vi
que me dice las cifras año tras año y
esto quiere decir que los consumidores
gastaron y 5 menos que el año pasado en
este día que le sigue al black friday
bueno y entonces nosotros también
contribuimos a no ser consumistas
masivos exactamente nos vemos más
adelante con más economía vamos a pasar
ahora a nuestro reportaje del día